за марення з потом жаби не годинник
британка елізабет готуватимуся до
тести для відкривання
німецького в рамадан ства важимо руки хто
міг рудник переїхала до берліну ванною
я ви це такий особливий могла пропливти
якщо референдуму сюди брексит
елізабет ви вирішила хочеться лиж це себе
громадян q & as a nice фронті я просто
на моргаю сезар би ти все 7 на закладено
новий потік на йоржова сценарію я подаю
заявку на ранок вони німецькому паспорту в
1 годину одягаюсь з барахти британської
дживан чи амон і завищуються в шкодувати
не батьком я як трава регулярно вигляд
винні і все ж таки я вирішую починала що вона
чує і сьогодні матч і не хотів
обрахунок такий шанс замало і на ступні
покоління має чув ні мечі не
проживають понад 100 тисяч британців
близько чотирьох з половиною тисяч даних
у берліні щоб стати хроматином ферми не
їм доводиться чика ти близько трьох місяців
подавати документи на німецький паспорт
хіба може і британці столітті прожив і
уе свої сім руки прямо британський
паспорт у них теж завищується
проте після виходу Великобританії з ес
вуса можна значно складні тася йому
вірна до видається роботи ви берна
користь 1 паспорта
розмив для брекситу його насадкою на
ритку можна пошану і у broke in english
тесс вайнер не те продуктів та екрани
їжте у берліні по на 20 років івл
залишитися в тиша і клієнта як можна
протезе знається ще й сама відпочивається
безпорадну штати також на зуб монети
своя калита ляльок і в спразі ня все упа
vitro можеш лише осадити і чика ти
sickle то судна провадиться іншому
бароном якуну дейл кишенька у берліні
вже 30 років проти США за 1 через
братів ви вирішила стати їх громадян до
юнімед чини
given a придбає не в тому ще прохання
тася британського громадян сло в тому
ще в сбер їх ти свої права як громадян
я з батька та вікном і на найкращий рахунок нас
було смішно йому вірна та скорботи та ми не
так бр ікру ще я могла просто так
запливом ви вирішите а по ньому в Берлін з
чим би мені а то перцем він і битися
альба наша громилою хоча чимало насичуємо
у тима не всі британці живуть вони меч і
не на устілці давно ще подавати
документи на грім агентство їмо
здогадається слідувати за світло невідомому
британському афоризму
з бригад зі шляхів і ти дали